- So, apparently something
really interesting
happened on Newsmax the
other day. Let's watch.
- Well, first mine was taken down
because we have all the election fraud
with these Dominion machines.
We have 100% proof.
- All right, so right off the bat,
you have Mike Lindell spouting off
some crazy conspiracy
theories about the election,
which have obviously been disproven.
- It was (indistinct)
- [Male Anchor] Mike. Thank
you very much. Mike, Mike.
You're talking about machines
that we at Newsmax have
not been able to verify,
- Hilarious. Newsmax then cuts him off,
because he's spouting some crazy nonsense.
- We just want to let people know
that there is there is nothing substantive
that we've seen. Let me
read you something here
- So as you probably know,
Newsmax got a Cease and Desist
Letter demanding a retraction
from Smartmatic and Dominion saying
that all this is crazy nonsense.
So, that's what they're reacting to here.
- While there were some
clear evidence of some cases
of vote fraud and election irregularities,
the election results in
every state were certified
- [Vlogger] Finally, Mike
Lindell stops talking